i
am such a huge fan of better call saul
and i am very curious
um have you guys started filming the
final season would you already be
tomorrow oh for real yeah i fly out in
the morning yeah
oh my god okay um is brian cranston
finally gonna direct an episode
this i do not know um i've only got the
first two
so uh i hope
that that happens i've heard that rumor
but i have not seen anything factual
that it's gonna happen yet
how long ago did vince tell you
has he told you ultimately where this is
all gonna go
or are you finding out script by script
i'm finding out script by script
i'm told that the wheels come off in
season six
and it explodes in a million directions
uh that sounds to me like there's a fair
amount of violence
but i don't know for a fact
we have a discussion where
my point of view is that
walter white became a angry
broken version of himself
and i wonder if it would be possible to
write
because i like the guy i wonder if it
would be possible to give
jimmy mcgill a better ending a better
place to end in
than he started in i don't know if
they're gonna
do that though one of the things that i
love
is all the black and white stuff at the
beginning and end
of seasons um could you sort of talk
about uh
uh that aspect of the show and how it's
so different than
what typically is out you know what i
mean like the ambitious nature
of the storytelling yeah um when you say
that
what i think about is i've often thought
there's no way we could do what the show
we've done
if breaking bad hadn't existed and not
simply because
saul was invented for breaking bad but
because
breaking bad trained
the audience to care about details
and to know that every little detail
will pay off and matter so because
they got everyone in the world
to see that that that could be
a story you're watching that if you
watch every little thing
it will matter one day then we got to do
better call saul which
is this quiet idiosyncratic
subtle quirky
show where things aren't running on
parallel tracks a lot
and you're like but you know you know
they're going to all come together
and they're all going to matter to each
other but you know that because you
watch
breaking bad and so we're very lucky
to to make this interesting show and
it's only because
breaking bad was so good that we get to
do better call saul